cette vidéo est sponsorisé par norvez pn
rendez-vous surnommée pay prends ou org
slash cyrus north pour obtenir un
abonnement de deux ans et quatre mois
supplémentaires gratuits avec une énorme
réduction plus d'informations en fin de
vidéo bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
cette nouvelle vidéo êtes-vous démerde
je rappelle très vite et le principe en
gros vous m'avez envoyé des histoires à
l'adresse qui s'affiche ici vous l'avez
fait via un service sécurisé que je vous
mets en descriptions ça permet de faire
en sorte que les histoires soient hyper
anonyme et donc du coup je ne peux pas
s'il se passe quelque chose etc voilà je
je je reçois l'histoire jeu là décrypte
avec vous et c'est tout mon rôle sa
clarté soir on la reçoit et on la juge
on se demande si vous êtes ou non une
merde car je précise si jamais vous êtes
une merde vous êtes une merde un moment
donné à un instant t sur une histoire ça
peut dire que vous êtes une mère de
manière générale dans votre vie et vice
versa vous pouvez être une mère général
dans votre vie et un moment donné sur
cette histoire ne pas être une mère
prenait un peu de distance par rapport à
ce format évidemment autre chose
vous avez dit vous avez dit quoi je sais
que cet été on fera frais de parts par
mois je crois une vie de toutes les deux
semaines doit être vous des mers
pourrait se demander si je filmais un
effectivement on pourrait changer voilà
c'est
fait comme ça mais en même temps
l'engagement de votre côté les pas très
fort c'est que vous payez pas par
exemple non non et la bande je sais pas
je sais pas on peut se demander si une
merde mais je trouve ça plus intéressant
de se demander si vous vous êtes des
merdes c'est parti avec l'autre chose
qui m'a pris mon crew
ya des moments je change de tenue et
c'est parce que des sessions tournage
entendre quelques uns pas après
j'entends d'autres des fois il ya
durable en asie histoire en trop mais
sinon la vie doivent être trop longue on
les garde pour après etc etc tout est
clair tout ça plus intéressant de se
demander si vous êtes des merdes c'est
parti
suivent une mère par voler un chien
you cyrus big up du moyen-orient' et à
l'international pick up
big up à tous les voleurs de chiens way
mon voisin adopter un chien et environ
un an le problème c'est qu'ils le
gardent est attaché à un poteau dans son
jardin sans jamais le promener ou jouer
avec quand je dis jamais c'est bien
jamais le chien faisait ses besoins dans
son propre espace ce que je trouvais
juste un fameux coup il aboyait
constamment et ça faisait chier tout le
quartier moins que j'ai déjà essayé d'en
parler aux maîtres mais il m'a juste dit
que si j'avais un problème je n'avais
qu'elle règle est que la police
pour qu'ils prennent pour rien il a pris
un chien c'est peut-être que la police
ici est complètement inutile mais
entendu elle n'a rien fait ici dans le
moyen-orient genre est ce que tu viens
de généraliser la police du moyen-orient
j'ai contacté une associée aux
productions des animaux mais elles n'ont
pas le pouvoir de confisquer un animal
maltraité elles ne peuvent qu'aider des
chiens de rue ou volontairement
abandonnés par l'armée du coup pour le
bien du chien a de tout le quartier mon
frère et moi avons décidé de libérer le
chien en pleine nuit et de l'amener à
une association à plusieurs heures de
route pour que son maître ne puisse pas
le retrouver on a aussi pris la chaîne
pour faire croire que le chien avait
finalement réussi à la casse et il
faisait que ça tous les jours mes amis à
qui j'en ai parlé sont partagés sur le
sujet suis-je une merde ah lalala lalala
intéressant des oufs intéressant de ouf
parce qu'en fait la question qui se pose
derrière c'est le statut qui donne à
l'animal ces concerts l'animal comme un
être sensible qui a des droits tu n'es
pas une merde tu l'a sauvé se
considèrent l'animal comme propriétaire
tu mets de côté le côté être sensible
tout ça tu oublies c'est juste une
propriété qui appartient à quelqu'un
passait un vol à mon sens n'est pas une
mère après ça reste un mot vide légal
soit le gars il est chez lui acheter un
chien le mec est un connard il a le
droit d'exercer sa connerie tu dois tu
vois ce que je veux dire moi ça me fait
ch et 1 ça me fait chier mais en vrai
après légalement je sais pas en tout cas
en france comment ça marche je vais
appeler le spécialiste des animaux sur
youtube
tanguy tout bête
oui tanguy tout pète vous êtes en plein
dans mon tournage de vidéos donc c'est
enregistré tout ça
avec ma grand-mère dont quelques vous
dérange pas si je vous écoute très bien
d'un ghetto fait merci de répondre à cet
appel à
ce genre en train de lire tellement fort
mal à être vous des merdes embauches
explique il ya un chien pendant un an le
propriétaire tu ailles le lait s'est
attaché à un poteau toute la journée
genre il le promenait jamais le chien il
faisait ses besoins dans son profil
tout à fait le chien il faisait ses
besoins dans son propre espace etc voilà
bref insupportable
légalement
légalement kangala c'est légal non je
crois que cal alors je crois qu'il ya
une loi sur les chiens la tâche ils sont
la chaîne fasse une telle taille et il
me semble que normalement je ne sais pas
si la loi exige qui file à chelles
charles présentant tu vois après si les
conditions se dégradent trop essayé d'en
sauvegarder tous cette donne clairement
de la maltraitance je sais pas où est la
limite entre le chien qui est attachée
et de chiens enfin tu vois normalement
légalement s'il a une grande chaîne ça
dois je sais pas il faut se renseigner
ok mais alors si c'est la maltraitance
animale est-ce que genre t'as le droit
de saisir et faire saisir le chien bah
oui mais par le biais d'une association
c'est à dire qu'il ya des associations
qui vont être entraînés mais assermentés
tu vois et qui vont pouvoir 11 /
constatations
réquisitionnés en fait des animaux mais
souvent c'est fait avec l'appui des
senteurs quand même quand tu vois des
vidéos de saisie d'animaux tu as
toujours cacho de la police derrière
deux longueurs d'onde quoi après caen 30
millions da luz par exemple qui saisit
déchets dans des conditions terribles et
tout dans des élevages soirée ou chez
des basques et compléter des câbles jeu
c'est toujours dans un cadre légal
s'adapter à un juge qui a ordonné que la
série était possible or ce qui est
d'ailleurs je sais que c'est très très
dur pour les bénévoles ce type d'
enquête parce que souvent avant d'avoir
leur donnant du juge pour pouvoir saisir
bas ils vont voir ils constatent y
filmer des animaux dans la merde en fait
le temps que leur donne le droit de
pouvoir y aller et c'est vrai que
forcément parfois ça doit être difficile
de laisser ces animaux dans la merde
mais ont même site que je pense des gens
qui travaillent à l'aide à l'enfance est
toujours des trucs genre ok après là
c'est particulier le gars il était au
moyen-orient et tout ok
les chiens il a volé le chien dont il a
bien fait voilà
un chien ça fait six ans qu'elle a petit
choc se reconnaîtra elle a volé à
un mec dans la rom dans la rue en fait
six ans ne tue pas trop mal qui était
clairement violent avec elle l'a vu
pendant deux jours et le petit chiot
était vraiment pls et se faisait battre
par le mec et tout est un moment bas
détournement d'attention les parties que
le chien ça fait six ans que la lhn elle
au top du top je pense qu'elle a une
meilleure vie que tu as qui lui était
promis avec le gac effectivement j'avais
totalement zappé ce concept clé de
maltraitance tu vas le mot-clé
maltraitance je n'ai pas sorti ah bah
ouais tu vois moi je sais par exemple
après c'est aussi celle à l'impulsivité
la détermination de chacun je veux dire
tu as des gens qui passent un cas de
maltraitance proment n'auront rien à
du cadre légal et iront sauver
l'animal tout de suite écoutons tu leur
coeur et leur bravoure tu vois et oui ça
je peux comprendre car allemands aussi
pour toi disait ok bah quelques juges il
ya oui ou non mais en attendant son
chien avec son collier qui lui rend
demain à pau ça va être ça je comprends
totalement et je suis plus de ceux de ce
côté là merci beaucoup tanguy tout
bêtement votre intervention de rien
cyrus ne
travaille surtout la belle personne que
tu es merci allez go bizzzouxxx voilà
non seulement tu es pas une merde non
plus tu as bien fait quoi c'est ce qu'il
fallait faire parce que ce truc de
d'imaginer genre le chien comme la
propriété du gars c'est pas possible là
ça serait nier son caractère vivant
serait soigné sa liberté tout ça mais
j'ai quand même commencé mon explication
avec ces deux idées là pour qu'on
comprenne le point de vue potentiel du
connard et le point du potentiel de tes
potes qui sont pas totalement d'accord
avec toi suis-je une merde pendant
l'essai mes potes sombré dans la drogue
bonjour bonjour quand j'avais 16 ans je
rencontrais des gens qui sont très vite
devenus mes potes proches il consommait
du cannabis mais ça ne posait pas de
problème un jour je savais que pour une
soirée et m'ont dit qu'il était chaud
pour essayer l'ecstasy j'essaye de les
raisonner mais se sont très vite braqué
en mode on s'en fout c'est notre vie on
fait ce qu'on veut tepa note darron
ok alors j'ai laissé passer mais j'ai
arrêté de fréquenter après ça et des
quelques photos que j'ai reçu deux ils
ont vraiment mal tourné est-ce que je
suis une merde pour les avoir laissé
tomber dans la drogue dure ben non mais
tu justement
tu les a prévenus tu leur as dit et ils
ont répondu tu vas pas les forces et toi
t'as essayé de les raisonner donc qu'est
ce que tu aurais voulu faire les forces
et genre leur prendre l'ecstasy brûlé
l'ecstasy jean tubize a pas laissé je
suis pas d'accord avec ce constat en
fait tu les as pas laisser sombrer dans
la drogue n'était pas d'accord avec eux
thaïs et de les raisonner tu leur as dit
ils n'ont pas voulu écouter
ils ont raison en fonte et palourdes
aaron tu vois en plus toi même tu avais
16 ans pas comme s'il avait 16 ans et en
avait dix de plus par exemple donc pour
moi non mais c'est triste pas de drogue
suis-je une merde d'avoir agi comme ça
avec lui alors les titres mais titre de
l'aide vous des merdes alors cet homme
qui les sélectionnent tom quand tu
sélectionnes si le titre il ne veut rien
dire comme ça devient l'histoire c'est
nous on veut du titre bonjour mr nombre
alors je précise que m r comme ça c'est
mister e ce monsieur cm points voilà
j'ai un fier d'écrire et cette histoire
est vraiment vraiment longue mais je
vois mal en coupé une partie où risquent
d'être biaisés wright évidemment tous
les noms ont été modifiés par souci
d'anonymat huawei pour cette histoire il
faut placer un homme de contexte elle se
passe à l'époque de mettre 17 ans je
m'ai 23 aujourd'hui c'était donc il y a
6 ans et je vais emménager dans une
petite maison perdue dans un minuscule
village de 1000 habitants tous les
villages autour sont du même type et le
lycée général du coin compte environ 500
élèves dans ce genre de région on le
sait il ya une ambiance différente de la
métropole dans laquelle j'ai grandi
chaleureuse family avec cet arrêt car
évidemment tout le monde se connecte
sauf moi le petit nouveau je me suis
rapidement fait des amis et j'ai
découvert que l'on pouvait aller se
bourrer la gueule dans des bas les
règles étaient justes pas les mêmes ok
donc tu étais pug 17 ans méthode déjà 17
ans mais je vais dans des bars je me
bourre la gueule l'abus d'alcool est
dangereux pour la santé n'oubliez pas
ensuite j'ai découvert que certaines
mentalités allaient bon train le genre
n'a été que je ne pouvais me contenter
d'ignorer l'époque par sens du devoir
vous paraît maturité je ne sais pas
xénophobie sinon racisme homophobie et
cetera je précise également que je suis
un homme voilà pour le contexte c'est
très clair il se trouve que dans ce
nouveau lycée plus qu'en ville j'avais
une certaine popularité auprès des
filles gain de popularité que je ne
m'explique toujours pas aujourd'hui
sûrement parce que c'était un pur beau
gars et je me suis rapproché d'une fille
de ma classe que nous appellerons clara
clara était bellocq et populaire en
auprès des garçons mais timide on s'est
rapproché de plus en plus et de fil en
aiguille on est devenus amis et sex
friend régulier au
moins 17 ans j'étais plus haut il n'y a
pas de route on se voyait une fois par
semaine en plus du lycéen soir en train
de bourrer la gueule dans un bar avec un
groupe de potes mais vermont n'avait pas
vécu les mêmes 17 ans j'entends quelque
chose qui attire on aurait de suite des
gens chantent en allemand un autre
groupe de jeunes dont la plupart étaient
également dans mon lycée et d'autres
plus âgés je repense au contexte il ya
juste avant xénophobe glycine ont
racisme joby et c est ce que c'est les
champs auquel on pense je ne fais pas
plus attention que ça ils ont l'air de
bien s'amuser et je reconnais dans le
groupe un type qui avait un crush clara
depuis plusieurs années s'était embrassé
plusieurs fois mais ne s'intéressait pas
vraiment à lui à moins d'être ivre pas
très cool pour le gars nous
l'appellerons albert albert patrick
brown quelques jours plus tard je parle
de ces canaux de potes qui était présent
dans le bar en question du champ mais
pas dans son groupe de potes il
m'informe avec un air un peu écoeuré tu
sais un anr un peu et courez pardon
c'est l'air que kong on vient pas de
courir l'air que vous avez convenait pas
de courir un salaire est court et il ma
forme avec un air un peu écoeuré que
c'était un chant nazi
ok ok un de ceux de la whey remarque
vite je ne sais pas ce que c'est la
loire match à la wehrmacht au gaz est
bon je sais ce que c'est assez l'armée
c'est l'armée du iiième reich oh là là
je vais me passer pour un oubli a créé
de venir il se trouve que dans la même
journée ok donc on est sur des champs de
l'armée allemande quoi du troisième
reich c'est marrant que c'est toujours
les nazis qui ont les mauvais rôles et
sauf que dans la même journée alors que
je flirte et gentiment et clara je
croise le regard d'albert un regard
mauvais aka mélange de mépris et de
haine je n'ai pas compris tout de suite
puis je me suis rappelé son crash
bientôt elle était parmi les types qui
chantait ce champ abjecte pour la
première fois de ma vie j'avais envie de
me battre au plus profond de moi même de
surcroît avec un type que je ne
connaissais que demain on est dans un
mois dans un shonen on est dans un film
d'action j'estime à vraiment et dans un
film d'action il ya du love il ya des
nazis des regards de mépris et y'a un
mec s'appelle albert et j'estime avoir
au moins une bonne raison de le faire
parce qu'on ne chante pas la gloire du
troisième reich allez mon gars à aller
j'ai pas comment il s'appelle mais ça
c'est bon ça c'est mon gaz ça c'est mon
gars j'ai donc entrepris de me montrer
le plus complices taquin est tactile
possibles avec clara tout en étant un
maximum à la vue de quiconque pourrait
en parler albert c'est à dire à peu près
n'importe qui puisque tout le monde se
connaît dans un des 7 500 élèves je
voulais l'emmerder le plus possible son
centre en contact avec lui de quelques
manières que ce soit et de saisir toutes
les occasions possibles de dire du mal
d'albert et de sa chorale de rappeler
autant que possible que c'est un nazi et
donc une mauvaise fréquentation
c'est une mauvaise fréquentation avons
beau monsieur en asie à force albert et
clara ont fini par s'éloigner à tel
point que pour leers à de clara albert
n'était pas invité ni lui ni sa chorale
et je pense que c'était la première fois
depuis des années qu'il n'était pas
invité l'un de ses amis en a même
rajouté une couche en lui racontant que
moi ne voulait pas voir de nazis à cet
anniversaire sinon je viendrai pas et qu
clara avait donc choisi moi son nouvel
ami plus plus depuis quelques mois plus
tôt que son ami d'enfance je mentirais
si je disais que ça ne m'a pas fait
plaisir je n'avais aucune empathie pour
sonic et je n'étais pas responsable des
choix clara ni des peines de coeur du
choriste ça clashe sa taille mais il se
trouve qu'un soir après une grande race
dans un bar un groupe de potes et moi
même distant de sortir prendre l'air
l'un d'eux me défier la course j'accepte
on se donne rendez vous avec les
marcheurs et le top départ est lancé on
avait fumé et bus j'avais deux ans et
environ 20 que le plus que lui
j'encaissais donc mieux toutes ces
substances et gagner la course haut la
main
une bonne minute d'avancé à vous prendre
rendez-vous complètement essoufflé à
deux points de vomir maîtrise tellement
j'ai couru trop vite parce que mon corps
est capable d'endurer ce stade d'ébriété
et voilà qu'arrive albert et de ses
potes bien plus avec moi dans ma
direction et un guet-apens ou quoi le
mec est dans un bar in store ils vont
prendre l'air il se tape une cour il
arrive à prendre à rêver de la course et
là albert qui arrive je le vois venir je
sais ce qui va se passer et je sais que
je ne peux pas me défendre une pousse
une fois je titube et l'insultent il
pousse une deuxième fois je tombe et
l'insultent encore au moment où mes
fesses touche le sol mon challenger fini
par arriver à destination lui aussi et
voit son ami sur le point de se faire
frapper oui il est ami d'enfance aussi
et oui il a pris ma défense barkat apens
il lève son point hésité je le regarde
dans les yeux et lui dit je suis pas en
état de défendre pour feeds en fera
point fort parce que si je me relève
demain je te tue on est dans un film ces
deux potes un cycle jeune challenger
l'en dissuader et mon groupe de potes
arrive et voilà que clara est une amie à
elle donc deux amis d'enfance d'albert
sans gueule parce qu'il fait il me
frappait comme s'il avait vraiment fait
je fini par rentrer chez moi et je
décide tout ça ne va pas en rester là
j'imagine que c'est là où tu as ta
commencent à agir comme une merde on
attend une semaine samedi soir rebelote
au bar mais cette fois je ne bois pas et
ne fume pas j'attends de voir albert
sortir pour évacuer la bière tu as fait
exprès de pas boire et les mecs lui la
bu il a tellement but qui va aller
pisser l'approché mauvaise déjà je le
suis le bar tout entier me suit du
regard certains et gold comment ça se
fait je peux choc dehors tu pètes le nez
d'un coup de poing et deux roues de jean
sa masse chacun d'un côté tu la grèce
quoi sauf que son groupe fait au moins
cinq fois la taille du bien ils étaient
une trentaine et surtout aucun de mes
amis ne s'est jamais battu ta vie est en
et ayant grandi toujours avec les mêmes
personnes résigné je fus en direction de
ma maison et vais me coucher avec une
main de deux fois sa taille habituelle
parce qu'évidemment une fois
l'adrénaline retombées donne un coup de
poing dans le visage de quelqu'un ça
fait mal je tapais tellement fort est
tellement mal que mon auriculaire droit
est encore aujourd'hui tordu après ça je
sais qu'une partie sur l'entourage était
très énervé contre moi normal mais je
sais aussi qu'une autre partie m'a fait
comprendre qu'il l'avait cherchée qu'il
avait besoin que quelqu'un le calme et
s'est éloigné de lui je le sais
notamment parce que je me suis rapproché
certains d'entre eux dans les mois qui
ont suivi on a eu une dernière
discussion j'ai fait comprendre que s'il
ne disait pas rapidement à ses potes
d'arrêter de m'appeler la nuit pour me
menacer c'est lui qui prendrait pour eux
puis on a plus jamais eu d'interaction
alors suis-je une merde
il ya plusieurs choses qui se mélangent
pour moi albert là il avait l'occasion
de frapper fort et il l'a pas fait il
tâte chamailler et c'est un machin mais
il n'a pas cassé la gueule quoi ce tube
et elle est cette vengeance le fait de
ne pas boire etc pas très fair play tu
vois si je mais surtout c'est violent
quoi au juste tu aurais pu ne pas
rentrer dans cette escalade là quoi tu
vois alors tu avais déjà la meuf que tu
voulais et qui voulait aussi tu avais
déjà gagné le match quelques parpaings
et là bas c'est un peu gratuit quoi d'y
aller lui casser le nez alors certes il
a ses champs et il fait partie d'un
groupe qui allait la d idéologie
nauséabonde
difficile de savoir dans quelle mesure
qu'il a pris pour faire partie d'un
groupe s'il le pense vraiment et si les
moteurs de ça et c'est enfin voila tu
vois je rappelle que vous aviez tous 17
ans pour moi y'a rien qui mérite
d'attendre comme ça en scred arriver et
bim le cabinet voilà ses bons côtés
d'aaron peut-être ne s'est pas tu vois
un champ que la violence ne résout rien
ça aurait été une dispute spontanée toi
ou genre en fait quand il avait agressé
et en a répondu et tu aurais péter le
nez à ce moment là à la bombe à ça
arrive tu vois voilà mais là le truc de
vengeance prémédité et tout moi c'est
plus ça qui me dérange en fait c'est ça
que c'est ça qui me ferait dire que là
dessus à ce moment là tu as été une mère
tout le reste non je trouve pas
effectivement n'est pas responsable des
choix de clara lui c'est ce que je vis
un moment effectivement tu as raison
aussi quand tu lui dis que bas les nazis
c'est pas de bonne fréquentation oui
c'est vrai ouf mais attendre d'agde de
le voir sortir le mec il a bu machin toi
tu as fait exprès de ne pas boire pas
fumer pour être pâques et bim je lui
casse le nez un truc qui me gêne la
banque
basse et senna gression en fait c'est
juste la nation même si lui et est agréé
ceci est d'une certaine manière la
semaine d'avant déjà moins forte white a
pas cassé un truc est tout
et puis c'était j'imagine que c'était
plus spontané tu vois pas ce que
j'aurais dit t'as vu c'est il était sous
le coup de l'alcool et toi aussi je sais
pas bref pour moi c'est faux pas
répondre c'est pas la loi du talion tu
vois c'est pareil pour oeil dent pour
dent en tout cas six ans plus tard
j'espère que tu vas bien je sais pas si
tu vois toujours clamé si tu la vois
j'espère que vous allez bien tous les
deux et on embrasse très forte en aurait
q la france entend suis-je une mais un
port laisser tomber comme ça salut cyrus
ça faisait quatre ans que j'étais en
couple avec ma copine de l'époque on
avait un grand projet ensemble partir
vivre un nom au japon
qu'est ce que j'aimerais vous êtes une
compagnie qui gère les visas et cetera
au japon faites moi vivre six mois au
japon souplet ont fait un partenariat on
avait réservé notre appartement ensemble
à tokyo calculer nos dépenses en
fonction de l'autre tout était planifié
à 2 mai environ six mois avant tout
quitter en france j'ai commencé à me
rendre compte que je l'aimé de moins en
moins j'ai décidé de me force non
utilisées de me forcer à rester légal
pas simplicité quand j'ai commencé à
être installées au japon et à voir mes
amis habitudes après environ quatre mois
je l'ait quittée en la laissant en plan
dans un appartement qui serait dur à
payer à elle seule j'avais trouvé une
coloc vraiment pas cher secrètement au
nom là
c'est quoi comme raison je lui ai dit
que je n'avais jamais avalé le fait
qu'elle m'avait trompé environ 1 enfant
partir malgré le fait qu'il avait
officiellement par donner à ce moment et
cousines vraie raison c'est une fausse
raison je lui ai jamais parlé du fait
que je reste avec elle par simplicité le
temps de munster pays étrangers alors
que je savais que je ne l'aimé plus je
disparais de sa vie sans même laisser
une adresse ou un numéro pour me joindre
quasiment du jour au lendemain suis-je
une merde
bah mon poteau
oui bah oui oui oui pays de merde tu
laisses quelqu'un comme ça toujours
lendemain en plan commence avec un n'a
pas tranché et toi secrètement pas
trouvé une petite colonne qui est ou non
c'est pas cool hein si tu en veux
été trompés que césar va t'en parles tu
en parles tu lui dis tu vois et vous
séparez que tu veuilles te force à
rester avec elle et c'est un machin je
pense que on est beaucoup homme ou femme
à avoir fait sa voix dans les couples à
cette dit vas-y je pense que ce couple
marché tient à être obstiné et tout mais
l'a lâchée en plan comme ça d'un coup
moi je trouve sympa cool apprête à
bourem parce que j'allais vivre à tokyo
c'est cool j'espère en tout cas que tu
es heureux aujourd'hui et que elle aussi
encore une fois c'est parce que tu as
été une merde là que tu admires toute ta
life mais on vous fait pas ça refait pas
ça mais ce panneau maison c'est pas une
raison sérieuse est-ce que je suis une
merde pouvoir fouiller dans les affaires
de mon mec
bonjour c'est luce bonjour alors
j'aimerais bien me faire juger et avoir
des avis car je suis perdu ok je suis
maladivement jalouse due à des
traumatismes du passé que je n'ai pas
résolu je suis en couple depuis trois
ans avec un homme que j'aime
profondément depuis le début notre
relation j'ai fait des crises pour
quasiment tous je suis très exigeante et
critique je sais qu'il m'aime je laime
aussi à tous les deux d'avis pour dire
que notre rencontre est exceptionnel on
a l'impression d'avoir rencontré notre
âme soeur dès que l'on s'est vu ça a été
magique je sais que c'est cliché mais
c'est vrai
j'ai présenté leurs auteurs je finirai
tout seul on se correspond en tous
points hormis ce fameux problème de
jalousie qui nous pourrit la vie je
travaille un déjà des foules lucide
c'est très bien je travaille énormément
sur moi pour régler ce problème je suis
passé par de nombreuses remises en
question est prise de conscience car je
me rends compte que mon comportement est
toxique j'ai fait beaucoup d'efforts en
trois ans j'ai beaucoup évolué jeu péter
un plomb regardez mes filles dans la rue
ça s'il vous plaît c'est bien que tu le
fasses plus mais paraissent aux gens
qu'il faut encore ne fait pas ça c'est
bon on regarde juste des gens dans la
rue là c'est bon
vous vous attendez à quoi qu'on fasse
j'y vais elle est mieux on peut juste
regarder ou pas c'est possible
évidemment on regarde
discrètement sans faire peser à la
personne qu'on regarde un quelconque
regard quand il répondait pas à mes
textos pendant cinq minutes je les kings
shame et plusieurs fois quand je
considérais que ça manquait de respect
je vois rien de grave ou de sérieux mais
simplement c'est des textos dérapé de
façon humoristique je le prenais mal
qu'est ce que king chez mais bon hein
kinks et une forme de fantasmes ou quoi
voilà sais rien moi moi mon king c'est
couché avec des matches comme perruque
voilà cinq inc et donc king chez mais
c'est pas vrai
c'est pas mon king moi je le dis mais
king chez aimé ce serait dire les gens
qui font ça chose annuler ou assez
pourri de vouloir coucher avec des meufs
qui ont des perruques que je parle de ça
c'est kitsch et oui j'ai été très
susceptibles très fermé je le juge est
fortement à chaque fois qu'il faisait
quelque chose que je jugeais allait
allant à l'encontre de notre exclusivité
et fidélité et je vais raconter toutes
mes histoires passées et et tromperie
que j'ai vécu désolé tvq tous sachent
que tous les hommes ne sont pas comme ça
évidemment ya à peu près 2% de mecs qui
compte très vite cet homme a confié de
lui même sens que je pose la question on
y apprend le sujet je te jure je te l
nous le jure les paras potes elle nous
je le jure qu'il ne se masturber jamais
que cette habitude n'existait pas dans
son fonctionnement qu'il n'y avait pas
bon tout simplement pas et qu'il se
pensait dysfonctionnelle jeudi pardon
mais celle qui a fait la faute et je les
accepte et même si je n'y croyais pas
totalement je n'ai pas posé de question
et j'essayais même de leur assurer
jusqu'à ce que jean ménage avec cette
personne alors arrêtons nous ici un
instant extrêmement rare
et extrêmement rare gens ne jamais se
masturber ou à l'orge ou alors je vis
dans un monde où avec tous mes potes et
moins on vit dans masturbe landes on
continue nos rapports sexuels étaient
extrêmement rare causant une frustration
chez moi et des questionnements je pense
à douter de moi de ma féminité de son
désir c'est lui en parler mais il n'y
est toujours le problème et n'écoutez
pas selon lui tout allait bien il me
reprochait les besoins ok alors ça me
choque moins du coup parce que peut-être
que juste il n'est pas
peut-être que ça il n'est pas trop c'est
que ce quoi ça me branche pas plus que
ce à quoi et donc du coup je comprends
que ne m'a sûrement pas ce que c'est pas
bien pas besoin il n'a pas envie
j'imagine qu'à un moment le corps et
avec lui tout seul d'une certaine
manière parce que sinon il ya la
production ans a produit sa produit il
faut délivrer
livraison à faire sinon c'est
s'entassent dans le stock voilà faut
lâcher du lest pardon pour les détails
sordides mais ne s'excuse pas on adore
ça mais plusieurs éléments au fil du
temps on peut penser qu'en fait il me
mentais à ce sujet ah ah donc tu penses
que ce serait pour ça que vous avez une
vie sexuelle
parce que estimation quand je m'absente
et longuement j'ai retrouvé des traces
équivoque et j'étais sûr que ça n'avait
aucun rapport avec moi vu que j'étais
pas là effectivement ça aide ça s'est
reproduit plusieurs fois trop de fois
entre parenthèses en fréquence très peu
assez pour que soit la source du
problème concernant notre propre
sexualité avec j'ai commencé à fouiller
de façon plus sérieuse car l'idée qu'il
me mente m'était insupportable
je précise que jusqu'à ce moment-là je
ne fouille est pas du tout je tombais
simplement sur des éléments qui auraient
mis tout à n'importe qui je vais
également absolument sûr qu'il ne me
trompe pas physiquement avec une autre
personne pour des raisons que je ne
nommerai pas et pour l'anonymat mais
cette hypothèse était à exclure on est
tous très curieux tout et tout cela j'ai
continué à trouver de plus en plus
d'éléments quai dans ce sens je sais que
c'est mal de fouiller dans les affaires
des autres gars donc la junte a commencé
à fouiller des coupes mais je voulais
vraiment rétablir la vérité je me
sentais trail et c'est insupportable de
voir la personne qu'on aime incapable de
se confier à moi même si je comprends
que je lis et départ oui c'est ça c'est
que la personne aziz sy pour un regard
je prend cher qu'est ce que c'est si
je me demande quoi même en lui mettant
les preuves sous les yeux il continue de
nier de mentir de justifier des
explications qui ne tiennent pas la
route et dans le daily news a dit tu l'a
confronté c'est bien il emmène il faut
savoir qu'il ait eu une éducation
religieuse et stricte aa et qu'il a
peut-être été culpabilisés par se faire
dans le passé et que ma jalousie au ru
et maladif n'a pas aidé ça me semble
être un très bon pronostic enfin
diagnostic plutôt aujourd'hui je m'en
veux terriblement d'avoir été si dur
avec lui je me dis que mon comportement
a engendré tout ça même si dans un sens
je suis sûr de ne jamais avoir abordé ce
sujet particulier avec lui c'est lui qui
a choisi d'en parler alors que je
demanderai du tout et en plus simplement
ne rien dire j'adore parce que c'était à
la fois à la fois tu te frappe à la fois
tu te console on voit que ça perturbe on
voit que ça travaille cette histoire je
me demande si ce mensonge est
pardonnable je sais qu'une personne qui
ment mentir a toujours mais peut-être
que cela ait bientôt points tim ou
traumatiques pour lui et que je dois
juste lui la paix car ça ne me
regarde pas vraiment moi je me paierais
te rassurer je suis pas d'accord pour
dire qu'une personne qui ment mentir a
toujours je pense que voilà chacun à son
code à ces règles peut-être que même si
elle ment là dessus et considère que là
dessus c'est ok mais pas sur d'autres
choses s'ils me ment sur la ils
pourraient me mentir sur bien d'autres
choses je pense pas évidemment ce n'est
que mon avis je précise que c'est
l'unique mensonge toujours marqué en
trois ans tu vois bien et comme il ce
sujet là notre couple se porte bien
nous avons des projets ensemble il est
plus engagé que jamais notre amour est
sincère ou bien est-il une mauvaise
personne de mme avoir menti de son plein
gré en sachant toute la souffrance que
cela a causé la perte de confiance etc
je précise que j'accepte évidemment qui
se masturbe le rêve n'est pas là son
mensonge que j'ai du mal à tolérer merci
beaucoup fouiller dans ses affaires
c'est pas bien il ya très peu de ces
constance qui pourrait pardonner de
fouiller dans les affaires ou pour moi
d'une certaine manière tu es une merde
avoir fouillé dans ses affaires je te le
dis mais attends tenir que je comprends
lui il est pas blanc comme neige c'est
difficile mais la même manière c'est
difficile ici de lanta situation de ne
pas aller satisfaire sa curiosité aidant
vous est dans une situation difficile
soit vous êtes pas d énormes merde des
petites merdouille
petit merde je suis avec vous
moi je veux qu'on prend ce garçon parce
que j'ai pu par le passé culpabiliser de
me masturber et ça me paraissait mais
hallucinant siège juste cet avis en fait
tu vois ces voix là et en fait c'est
quand j'ai senti je crois que la
personne que j'avais en face de moi
était plus jalouse que ce que j'avais
l'habitude d'avoir et donc cette
personne qui virait trop mal et c'est
très agréable de culpabiliser pour ça
c'est un truc que je jamais faire quoi
et j'étais une partie de moi était
intimement persuadé de faire du mal à
personne qui était le cas sirius
insurgés du passé je te le dis tu
faisais du mal à personne sauf peut être
un système de consommation et ça c'est
autre chose mais voilà même si je le
savais il ya un truc qui me gênait oms
est parti maintenant maintenant c'est
parti
aucune culpabilité alors voilà alors là
mais par apple pour mes fouiller dans
les affaires c'est plus dur mais réussir
à lui faire accoucher le truc où
effectivement comme tu le dis à un
moment tu dis peut-être que je dois
juste lui foute la paix s'il ya dans la
vie c'est ça tu es sûr qu'il trompe pas
avec une autre 9 etc ouais tu sais ce
qu'il attend et en parler tu vas
peut-être qu'il a point est en parler
c'est cesson c'est son jardin secret
tout en allant le fouiller sa bon ben au
moins tu as été persuadé que voilà c'est
potentiellement ça c'est pas autre chose
maintenant que tu le sais moi je leur ai
dit au fait si tu te branler
sache que c'est ok dès que je m'en fous
je sais que tu le fais pas même si tu as
même entier que tu le faisais je serai
ok avec ce je t'embrasse très fort je
souhaite beaucoup d'amour à tous les
deux
j'espère que quoi attendez il ya
quelqu'un que vous parlez
et c'est cyrus north vpn
norvez pn est un vpn virtual private
network un réseau privé virtuel en gros
ça vous permet deux choses principales
la première si vous protège et notamment
lorsque vous êtes sur des sites non
sécurisés genre hcsp et non https ben ça
va chiffrer les transferts de données et
la deuxième chose que ça peut faire
c'est faire croire au monde que vous
êtes et que par ce rappel est donc pas
forcément là vous êtes à titre personnel
j'utilise dès que je suis dans les
réseaux wifi publics etc voilà mais je
l'utilisé aussi pour faire croire que je
suis ailleurs alors ça peut servir pour
regarder du catalogue netflix par
exemple que vous n'avez pas dans votre
pays mais ça peut aussi servir à rentrer
dans des sites qui sont bloqués en
france par exemple c'est rapide c'est
efficace c'est sur tout les tous les
trucs c'est sur le téléphone c'est sur
la tablette c'est sur l'ordinateur voilà
c'est multi comptes etc obtenir
l'abonnement de deux ans avec quatre
mois supplémentaires gratuits et une
énorme production ça se passe sur nos
rvm org slash cyrus north évidemment
c'est satisfait ou remboursé les 30
premiers jours voilà donc comme ça vous
pouvez l'essayer etc et vous rendre
compte à quel point c'est fluide je les
remercie grandement de se contrôler
cette vidéo et je les comprends en même
temps parce que quand on est une merde
part on apprend que ça se sache du coup
dans le pen
forcément en tout cas j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a plu je vais essayer de
continuer d'en faire une par mois à peu
près voulez pas vous pouvez balancer aux
histoires j'explique tout en
descriptions ah oui et quand vos
histoires supplée de mémoire le genre et
le et l'âge ce que ça peut changer des
choses en fait sur le jugement vous
embrasse très fort je souhaite une
excellente soirée love peace ciao
[Musique]
d'accord